vous avez été victime d'inceste pendant
des années pour parler plus clairement
de viol c'était entre vaud 11 ans et vos
16 ans est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
en quoi consistaient ces agressions
qu'il est comme était moi je connais
assurent non un certain trickett qui
était-il et quelles étaient ses
agissements voilà je sais que c'est pas
très facile je vous demande de le dire
avec vos mots en facile de 6 parce que
ça fait huit ans que je raconte mon
histoire parce que elle est
systématiquement libératrice pour les
autres victimes qui se reconnaître
qu'ils se reconnaissent dans mon nom mon
témoignage et qui donne beaucoup de
courage à ceux qui sont dans le silence
encore donc je si je pouvais le
multiplier tous les jours je le ferai
mais je vais vous donner l'apparence
suis pas loin mais en fait comme tout
prédateur qu'on a tous pédophiles ce
cricket ils avaient
toutes les valeurs les bonnes valeurs
que l'on peut retrouver dans le sport
quelqu'un de serviable arrangeant
disponibles gentil apprécié de tout le
monde il y avait surtout la confiance de
mes parents qui sont les premières
victimes de ce prédateur puisque il
avait commencé par gagner la confiance
de mes parents qui sont aujourd'hui
encore dans le traumatisme dans la
culpabilité et à chaque fois j'ai
beaucoup d'émotion pour mes parents
parce que sont pas guéris ou encore de
ceux de ce2 ce2 ce qui m'est arrivé
parce qu'ils me jeter dans la gueule du
loup tous les vendredis j'avais
tellement confiance en lui qu'il fallait
que je parte avec lui que je rentre avec
lui des entraînements de rugby ou des
répétitions de musique est ce que ça
n'est pas mes parents alors si je rentre
avec quelqu'un d'autre j'étais punir
semaine suivante d'une de ses deux
activités puisque j'avais désobéit avait
mes parents mes parents est ce que
savait pas mais parce que c'est un
minutes avant de me ramener me violer
cinq minutes après buvait le café avec
mes parents voilà comment fonctionne un
prédateur cas de la famille c'était le
mari de ma cousine et ma cousine qui
malheureusement jeu considéré à l'époque
comme ma soeur
quand je lui ai annoncé ce que ce que ce
qu'avait fait son mari sur moi m'a juste
dit mais je savais mais bon c'était
compliqué c'est et voilà il ya eu une
inversion de l'an à votre votre cousine
dès que j'ai pu parler en fait moi j'ai
pu parler grâce aux anchois ses 18 ans
dans le silence et dans
l'autodestruction comme beaucoup de
victimes avaient des pas des addictions
mais quand on est victime on n'est pas
borderline on est juste boutiste donc
moi ç'a commencé très jeune dans la
violence sur le terrain en dehors
extrêmement violent à prayssas et et
l'alcool c'était un moyen aussi de
c'était une excuse pour se battre aussi
quand on était alcoolisé après ça a
était l'argent quand je commence à
gagner de l'argent j'étais interdit de
casino et le sexe et bien sûr pour se
prouver qu'on est et hétéros et aux
homos
comme il nous le disait à l'époque on
reviendra pas en arrière si tu dis ce
que je te fais mais je dis à tout le
monde que tmp
dlc complet là vraiment le rugby et leur
sexualité à l'époque n'étaient pas
compatibles le sport non plus ça
commence à changer un petit à petit mais
on est encore loin de là c'est les
développements vous avez vous avez
développé par voie la suite à ces
agressions mais si je reviens à la
période quand vous avez 11 ans vous
subissez les premières agressions
j'imagine que vous voulez vous confier à
quelqu'un cherchait un soutien de l'aide
d'une protection non parce qu'en fait on
comprend pas ce qui nous arrive on est
dans un état de sidération et puis là
mais hormis ce surnom on peut pas le
dénoncer parce que l'on peut pas croire
peur de pas être cru un sentiment de
vente aussi de culpabilité pourquoi j'ai
pas dit non merde c'est dans cette
bagnole pourquoi je me suis pas défendu
et est du coup bd qui me ramenait et
bien il était là aussi
la première fois qu'il m'a agressé il
m'a raccompagné jusqu'à la maison moi je
suis parti dans les toilettes j'ai vomi
je me suis regardé dans la glace j'ai
pleuré une dernière fois 11 ans admis et
là j'ai commencé à comprendre ce que
c'était et
j'ai eu une anesthésie émotionnelle de
mes onze ans et demi jusqu'à mes 34 ans
a le jour du procès le 29 mai 2013 quand
il a gagné partie menotté pour dix ans
et dont il n'a fait que quatre ans et
demi mais ça c'est un autre débat mais
voilà toute cette période mais je n'ai
pas versé de larmes de mon corps et dans
voilà l'état dans lequel j'étais
pourquoi je me suis pas défendu mes
seins et xvième siècle c'est à dire que
vous aviez pas d'empathie pour les
autres ni rien aussi où ça avait de
l'empathie mais je n'arrivais pas à
verser de larmes de mon corps je peine à
n'importe quel sujet que ce soit sur
votre cas ou dans d'autres cartes ou et
la corvée perdre à quelques uns en
accord je ne pouvais pas pleurer c'est
mon corps ne pouvait pas s'exprimer
n'avait aucune émotion au visage et est
devenu insensible une statue statut mais
par contre bon j'étais en ébullition à
l'intérieur j'étais obligé de s'ouvrir à
l'extérieur parce que bon on pouvait pas
dénoncer ce type je connais trois
victimes aux carences de ce prédateur et
les trois avoir eu le même changement de
comportement brutal et soudain au même
moment
pour vous dire combien il était bon de
prédateurs ont joué dans la même équipe
de rugby ou dans le même collège dans la
même veine da et dans le sud-ouest 60
ans peut-être que je viens du sud ouest
je suis quelqu'un du terroir d'ailleurs
pour j'aime la chance à quelqu'un de
traditionnels alors s'il vous plaît
par leur président
quel âge avait-il l'huile à 11 ans
toujours de plus que moi dans un de plus
donc j'avais 11 ans il en avait 22 donc
il savait très bien ce qu'il faisait
nous on savait deux autres victimes vous
parlé avec simon et eric
oui on est et on est trois études mais
vous étiez au courant dont on était
inséparable c'est là où il est bon exact
river les deux et nous à l'e3 il nous a
dissocié les trois et on s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait des fois où nous
voyez des trois dans la même journée
sans qu'on s'en rende compte et voilà
c'est ça la force de ces prédateurs ils
avancent masqués ils avancent masqués
parce qu'ils ont les qualités que peut
avoir n'importe quelle bonne personne et
ils avancent masqués parce que mais
voilà ils ont cet amour en plus des gens
parce que c'est le gars qu'on mettait au
bout de la table parce qu'il faisait
rire tout le monde mais c'est un schéma
que je vois chez tellement de victimes
malheureusement
on est des copier coller après sur les
comportements non il y en a qui vont
être intervertis d'autres extraverti
qu'au moment il fallait que je n'existe
il fallait que je mets ces comportements
que vous développez petit à petit ça
devait quand même attiré l'attention
autour de vous de vos parents de vos
proches au rugby et ben voilà on avait
trois débiles qui mettait des coups de
poing à tout le monde sur le terrain à
l'époque ça faisait voilà ça faisait
peur adversaires quand se mettaient
minable au bord du comptoir au pied du
comptoir après une troisième mi temps
mais voilà ça arrive il y en a plein de
copains qui font ça et qu'ils n'ont pas
été déjà tissé inaperçue la passe
inaperçu à part que nous on en voyait
quand même beaucoup de signaux mais à
l'époque à 30 ans à l'arrière il ya une
personne qui était formée aujourd'hui
voilà on commence à former beaucoup de
gens pour identifier avec l'aso que j'ai
démonté en forme des gens pour des
éducateurs des professionnels car la
mère de l'association mais vous avez un
peu anticipée vous avez parlé procès de
condamnation dont il a bien fallu qu'un
jour vous parliez qui est un déclic que
vous sortiez de cet état de presque
d'hypnos quoi de sommeil émotionnel
comment ça s'est passé et ce qui est un
événement qui a déclenché sa
mon ex femme qui avait voulu inviter
mathieu la première victime que j'avais
perdu de vue depuis 10 ans et il lui dit
ben écoute je viens anniversaire j'ai
fêté mes 30 ans il vient jamais à
l'anniversaire qu'à une condition c'est
que cricket ne soit pas là il ya dedans
pourquoi cricri tout le monde adore
parce qu'il m'a violée
donc c'est parti de là et moi je suis
rentré le soir elle me dit bon il faut
que je te dise quelque chose je voulais
faire la surprise et d'inviter mathieu
et il a des conditions jugées un temps
gelé ça fait dix ans que je les ai pas
vus il mais en plus des conditions pour
venir c'est quoi ce bordel est en fait
il a été violé par criquette et puis là
bon moi j'ai pas pu parler de suite
parce que 18 ans de silence c'est pas en
claquant des doigts qu'on va les sortir
donc nuit blanche et le lendemain elle
m'a appelé j'étais sur la route elle me
dit bon voilà comment ça se passait avec
lui et l'a en fait elle était en train
de raconter mon histoire donc je suis
rentré et l'âge et j'ai lâché j'ai lâché
la bombe à fragmentation jusque dans une
famille c'est une bombe à fragmentation
j'avais une très grave de famille que
j'ai perdu 18 cousin cousine de 12 ans
que les tentes j'ai plus personne à part
mes parents bien sûr ils vont tourner le
dos au monde tournait le dos et puis
c'est un sujet qui fait peur aussi et
puis le nom de la famille tu vas quand
même temps porter plainte pour le nom de
la famille datant du 20 ans qu'est ce
qui nous fait chier avec ça moi j'ai
entendu plein de choses et des coups de
poignard dans le dos bon j'ai connu ce
que c'était ma première dépression c'est
j'ai arrêté le rugby pendant une saison
alors que c'est ma passion depuis l'âge
de 5 ans et demi parce que j'étais en
dépression je n'avais plus de motivation
j'étais écoeuré j'ai regretté maman
d'avoir parlé parce que j'avais perdu
mais tout ce que je pensais autour de
moi qui allais être un soutien bien sûr
et puis et puis voilà et le mariage que
du bon
j'ai tenu bon j'ai porté plainte avant
de porter plainte je veux voir la
troisième victime pour lui dire bon voir
ce qui s'est passé pour mathieu pour moi
pourquoi pas toi puisqu'on était les
trois inséparables mais moi aussi sauf
que depuis malheureusement à l'époque où
ans était la loi c'était attouchements
des agressions sexuelles ce n'est pas
des viol donc lui il avait le délai de
prescription qui était dépassé il n'a
pas été reconnue comme victime dans la
visite par la justice mais il était
victime lui aussi donc il venu témoigner
à la barre il nous a servi son
témoignage nous asservir nous aussi pour
les éléments supplémentaires dans le
dans le procès est donc
le procès est arrivé trop jours de
procès c'est là où mais vous de vous
parler de la famille qui tourne le dos
ou est ce que quand on s'adresse à la
justice qu'on dépose plainte vous avez
reçu un accueil où on prend au sérieux
la parole de la victime quand elle quand
elle parle d'inceste de viol g c'est
triste à dire mais dans mon parcours de
victimes et j'ai eu de la chance
énormément de chance je suis tombé sur
une psychologue et victimologue et
criminologue et qui m'a accompagné dans
ma résidence je suis tombé sur un
capitaine de gendarmerie qui m'a filé
son numéro de portable que ça va pas tu
m'appelles je me rappelle était sur le
gervais il me dit monsieur bois et
j'arrive lundi vous venez à la brigade
on va discuter j'avais besoin d'être
rassuré et je suis tombé sur mon avocat
fred lyonnais qui a été pillé dans ma
résidence et qui est devenu mon parrain
tellement que j'ai un lien fort avec lui
je devrais pas dire ça aujourd'hui j'ai
eu de la chance dans mon parcours de
victimes évolue même lecture n'ont pas
cette chance là bien sûr que l'on
s'améliore il y en a qui vont dire que
l'on mais moi je vous dis que oui c'est
sur le terrain tous les jours de plus en
plus de gendarmes de policiers qui sont
formés à accueillir à auditionner des
victimes il ya des spécialistes d'avocat
il ya des des brigades des mineurs il ya
plein de choses qui font que la victime
peut être bien accueillie il suffit que
le terme sur la bonne personne mais je
n'aurai plus de lire aujourd'hui elle a
de la chance j'espère que dans d'ici
2024 nous on se donne parce qu'on est un
peu dans le champ sportif 2024 pour
qu'il y ait vraiment tous d'aplomb
pareil comparé à d'autres pays mais on y
arrive on avance l'état dans le bon sens
on avance dans le bon sens est-ce que
vous avez éprouvée pendant le procès
de la peur tous les sentiments que
j'avais sur un terrain la pression la
peur et la libération en fait c'est ça
que on n'avait pas demandé le huis clos
d'un race au conseil de mon avocat on
n'avait pas demandé le huis clos parce
que le huis clos protéger aussi le
prédateur et nous on voulait mettre ce
type sur la place de la halle du village
veut dire ben voilà le cricket que vous
aimiez tous voilà ce qu'il a fait il
s'est excusé
et votre cousine qui était leur elle
était au courant des faits est-ce
qu'elle a eue elle une sanction
judiciaire alors elle a une sanction
judiciaire parce que j'ai dit sur un
plateau concurrents qu'elle était au
courant elle a marre assigne en justice
pour diffamation sauf que dans son
procès verbal set marqué noir sur blanc
qu'elle était au courant donc elle tu es
condamné pour ça elle n'a pas été
condamnée par rapport au fait qu'elle
était au courant parce qu'ils ont estimé
que du moment qu'elle était au courant
il n'y a pas eu d'autres victimes et
donc ça n'a pas fait d'elle une
une
campane
630 parce que par pardon de fermer ces
sacs absolument aberrant c'est
qu'effectivement je veux bien comprendre
que quand les gens sont au courant ils
se disent que de révéler les choses ça
va détruire la famille mais ce n'est
plus acceptable parce que c'est de la
non assistance à personne en danger et
je pense que la ville devrait être
beaucoup plus sévère avec l'entourage
qui c est qu il ne dit rien parce que
malheureusement c'est bien bien souvent
le cas parfois même c'est la mère qui au
courant des deux fait de son mari sur
ses enfants et qui ne dit rien je
comprends c'est pas facile mais en tout
cas on ne peut plus accepter aujourd'hui
dans les êtres dans un des messages à
faire passer ce sens dans ce silence et
cette omerta parce que ces véritables
une en assistant une véritablement
parlant de l'émotion parce que c'est des
situations tellement dramatique c'est
véritablement des non assistance à
enfant en danger mais il faut faire
passer dans son frère et merci pour
votre témoignage est infini à la parce
que plus on en parlera plus les gens
entendront ça plus les enfants
entendrons parce que beaucoup de
victimes pensent que en fait c'est
peut-être autorisé quelque part parce
que les prédateurs eux laissent penser
qu' on doit pas le dire mais c'est pas
complètement interdite et ça on devrait
vraiment faire une pédagogie immense
autour des enfants à l'école partout et
certainement ce que vous faites avec
votre association pour expliquer à un
enfant que c'est interdit par la loi
rien que ça c'est important je voulais
en venir à l'association justement
colosse aux pieds d'argile est ce que
c'était une évidence pour vous que
c'était pas seulement votre cas il
fallait exposés mais qu'il fallait venir
en aide aux autres à travers votre
association non c'est quelque chose qui
a mûri pendant le fut pendant le procès
et du moment que j'ai libéré ma parole
je commence à parler dans mon temps mon
entourage horrible ça et j'avais des
copains qui avaient un peu le même
comportement que moi et j'allais les
voir jeudi mais attend on se ressemble
un peu quand même oui mais moi aussi je
n'ai jamais parlé et pendant le procès
en fait j'ai fait quatre nuits blanches
et j'ai dit mais comment je peux faire
pour aider les autres victimes pour
aller
protéger ses enfants libéré surtout et
parce qu'un enfant plus jeune il va être
libéré - ce le traumatisme va
s'installer c'est mécanisme
d'autodestruction combien places pour
s'installer et aussi il faut savoir que
plus victime va porter va par les jeunes
elle ne reproduira pas aussi pour 40%
d'entre eux les actes qu'elle a suivi et
de ce
mardi nuit par exemple vous avez des
rêves encore récurrent de cette époque
non non c'est tout a été nettoyé par la
suite je suis résident à 100% pour
preuve j interviens aussi maintenant
place aux auteurs de violences sexuelles
en détention pour éviter la récidive
pour leur faire comprendre l'impact
parce que c'est important parce que
beaucoup reproduise dès leur libération
et là on a un nouveau projet en maillage
avec la fédé de rugby dont on sait pas
s'il va être validée encore mais on veut
intervenir sur les enfants qui sont
suivis par la pjj le démineur donc
hauteur pour éviter justement cette
récidive parce qu'il y en a 35 % qui
reçu récidive après avant leurs 18 ans
donc c'est énorme encore soucier ce
chiffre vous les victimes parmi les
prédateurs en allant des victimes ils
sont devenus auteurs et qui vont
évidemment sont fait arrêter et qui vont
reproduire avant leurs 18 ans et demi
donc il ya un accompagnement à faire
aussi face à ces auteurs qui sont pour
la majorité
victimes de violences sexuelles dans
leur enfance et moi j'étais surpris en
polynésie où plusieurs fois en prison et
face à 19 auteurs un pédocriminels tous
pas ne sont pas tous pédophiles mais des
pédocriminels
la plus grande majorité m'ont dit qu'ils
avaient été victimes et souvent il ils
ont ils ont libéré leur parole après mon
témoignage ce qui est énorme mais donc
essayer de briser la chaîne on a mené ce
qu'il est possible de faire de la
prévention est ce qu'il est possible de
mesures des anciennes écuries détecter
des comportements d'alerté sur certains
comportements est ce que c'est possible
c'est le coeur de métier puisque jeudi
métier parce que notre association j'ai
décidé de professionnaliser notre combat
pour en faire leur métier pour c'est
bien d'intervenir mais après il ya tout
ce qui va après la libération d'un
parole donc on a un pôle psychologie
comme pôle juridique et on peut surtout
multiplié les actions et les 21 salariés
aujourd'hui n'est que je salue
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils sont tous
motivés à libérer cette parole est et
on a mis 1 600 interventions là depuis
depuis janvier on a sensibilisé vers
1000 personnes énorme sensibiliser et
former ces normes oui lorsqu'on à
professionnaliser notre combat parce
qu'on m tous les jours sur le terrain ça
fait huit ans que chez sur le terrain
quatre ans que ce n'est devenu ma
profession n'y a pas eu une fois lors de
mes interventions je n'ai pas eu de
victimes face à moi que ça soit en école
primaire à partir de 8 ans que ce soit
en collège en lycée que ce soit un club
sportif toutes les catégories que ce
soit en formation avec vern adultes
systématiquement du moment qu'on
intervient dans le public là je parie
qu'il ya des victimes c'est ça le c'est
ça qui est terrible c'est que partout où
on passe il ya des victimes c'est 6
millions 700 mille 6 millions 700 mille
victimes d'inceste en france mais il
faudrait pas ce qu'est la prévention à
l'école en fait dans une classe juste
combien d'enfants estime-t-on ont été
prises alors les chiffres donnent aux
deux mois je vous invite à venir sur moi
sur une intervention avec moi sur une
intervention dans une école on parle de
toutes les violences sexuelles à partir
du moment qu'ils sont équipés d'un
portable j'ai eu encore le cas hier
j'étais pour l'urss à paris nous allons
travailler à une grosse journée
on avait des petits groupes de verre
mais tous avaient reçu 1 500 photos
d'une personne qui connaissait pas ou
qu'elles demandent quel âge de sixième à
partir de sixième mais du moment qu'ils
sont équipés d'un portable ils reçoivent
des saloperies comme ça bernard padaré
voulait parler d'abord merci encore une
fois ce métier même si je connais bien
sûr l'histoire j'imagine parker d'abord
on un partenariat effectivement qui sert
eto'o tente de jouer mais je peux te
garantir que mais je combats le combat
le combat le renouveler et tu parlais de
prévention mais c'est très très
important on a mis on a fait deux choses
avec avec matthieu mabin numéro d'appel
les gens pour les gens qui sont dans les
clubs on a mis ensuite mail sos
violences @ sfr.fr la vice présidente
est chargé de ce secteur me disais plus
de 100 appels en un an ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire attention il ya un
comportement de l'éducateur d'un
bénévole d'un dirigeant qui me semblent
du tout de suite on met la machine
en activation est ça qui est très
important dans la prévention est
importante et la deuxième chose c'est la
formation de nos éducateurs et nous
aujourd'hui on a signé avec avec marlène
schiappa la semaine dernière une audio
pour préparer les gens à des
radicalisations mais on a aussi préparé
les gens
contre les violences contre les
violences faites faites aux jeunes parce
qu'un éducateur il a bien sûr pour rôle
d'enseigner le rugby mais il n'ya pas
que ça c'est une évidence et pour ça il
faut qu'ils soient formés parce que
souvent ils me disaient mais comment
pouvait il faut être formé et donc sur
le rôle des associations comme saint
sébastien c'est primordial il faut se
sont relayés par les fédérations c'est
une évidence et je vous garantis elles
seraient ces violences @ sfr.fr ça
fonctionne nous qu'est-ce qu'on fait
tout de suite auprès de la gendarmerie
regarder aller voir le club allait voir
le président et puis continuer sur ce
tour mais des fois des fois y'a rien
mais au moins les déchets et
heureusement ouais mais encore une fois
la prévention elle est
fondamentale et ensuite c'est
intéressant évidemment votre
intervention sébastien parce qu'on est
parti quand même en 2009 à 2 millions
d'inceste on est à 6 millions 7
maintenant à dire que c'est exponentiel
et après 260 milles gamins qui sont
abusés donc c'est quelque chose de
phénoménal manque l'argent c'est aussi
qu'il ya plus de gens qui et oui qui ce
qui révèle qu'il
faut savoir garder l'argent déclare que
le gouvernement bouge et d'ainsi adrien
taquet a fait quand même du boulot avec
la plateforme afin d'être plate forme
qui est quand même intéressante à mettre
en avant mais il faut compter pas que
sur le gouvernement avec des numéros
d'appel est autre chose il faut compter
aussi sur le monde associatif je pense à
l'association que soutient cyril les
papillons ou alors mon ami capitaine de
police laurent boyer est ingrat qui
n'est pas aidé leur homme oui mais je la
location nationale ils vont pas d'un but
ce garçon là mais les boîtes aux lettres
pour permettre aux enfants ne peuvent
pas parler de mettre des petits mots
dans cette boîte aux lettres et les
mettre dans les écoles et les collèges
il faut savoir qu'il a mis le
représentant en france qui sont capables
de le faire et il faut savoir qu'à des
collèges des inspecteurs d'académie des
responsables académiques de l'éducation
nationale qui refuse
de me dire le savent c'est scandaleux
donc il faut que tout le monde se
prennent par la même le suis pour qu'on
vienne vraiment en aide à laurent qui
est un formidable le personnage
capitaine de police on reconnaît souvent
ce qui lui est arrivé malheureusement
mais c'est un engagement de long terme
mais ensuite et vous le disiez très bien
c'est la formation des gens pour prendre
en charge ces gars bien parce que c'est
tellement exponentielle la problématique
on tombe sur les gosses on a besoin de
gens formés en termes psychologie
psychiatrie autres et ça la bataille
n'est pas encore gagnée on a encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire là dessus je
vais pas revenir sur sur l'association
de loi ont effectivement je comprends
son désarroi je pense qu'il faut se
structurer avant d'intervenir faut pas
se retrouver avec un bout de papier à
faire une enquête dans une école pour
savoir qui a posé le papier je pense
qu'il a peut-être un outil qui peut être
bien c'est intéressant mais on a
malheureusement beaucoup de retours mais
aussi de cette association je salue son
travail je salue bien sûr son témoignage
je lui ai déjà dit je dis encore une de
ses collaboratrices à midi il faut
qu'ils se structurent son travail parce
que il ya des dysfonctionnements je
pense que ça peut être quelque chose qui
efficace mais il faut qu'ils se
structurent simplement la formation de
ces bénévoles nous tous les fon tous les
intervenants de l'association ça c'est
très important le format sur les
actionnaires de rio et vida tous les
tous les intervenants de colosse aux
pieds d'argile sont formés à l'accueil
de la parole de la victime c'est à dire
qu'on va avoir une posture face à des
victimes jusque systématiquement qu'on
intervient on la reçoit
systématiquement il faut avoir la bonne
posture et quoi faire de ce témoignage
on a des passerelles des avait des
commissariats des procureurs des
groupements de gendarmerie justement
pour faciliter cette libération de la
parole mais surtout la compagnie c'est
bien de la libérer après il faut la
compagne de suivi le travail le plus
compliqué c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
professionnaliser notre combat c'est
justement après le post interventions et
c'est ce qui est primordial parce que
venir intervenir libérer la parole une
fois elle va se libérer un an après et
soigné parce que appelé après qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait des êtres humains c'est
bien qu on est structurée comme ça vous
avez des subventions de l'état on a des
aides étatiques mais non faut
professionnaliser notre combat on a été
obligé de tarifs et nos interventions
comme je dis souvent celui qui a envie
de faire la chose trouver les moyens
celui qui a pas envie trouve des excuses
donc
si on veut et bonne forme et non mais
voilà donc il faut professionnaliser ce
combat qui est nécessaire et ô combien
compliqué par rapport à ce qu'on reçoit
alors qu'ailleurs merci beaucoup pour
votre témoignage et pour le travail que
vous faites c'est extrêmement important
vous avez dit vous étiez engagé en tout
cas dans la prise de parole depuis huit
ans or cette année une année très
particulière ces sujets là puisqu'il ya
eu le mythe ou inceste au début de
l'année qui a permis à énormément de
gens de s'exprimer ce que je comprends
de votre témoignage et de ce qu on
entend généralement c'est que ce qui
caractérise l'inceste c'est surtout le
silence et le fait que les victimes en
fait dès lors qu'elle s'exprime soit
expulsé en fait de leur cercle familial
parce qu'en réalité il ya un consensus
social a s'est établi autour du fait que
l inceste même quand il est connu par
les gens de l'entourage on préfère
protéger les agresseurs plutôt que de
protéger les victimes est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment qu'avec cette parole
qui a été qui s'est davantage répandu
cette année notamment avec ce mythe ou
inceste que votre travail est rendu plus
facile et comprendre mieux ce que vous
faites ou es ce que vous avez
l'impression que c'est toujours aussi
aussi compliqué comparable à north bay
le sujet sur la table donc c'est
beaucoup plus facile que quand j'ai créé
l'association il ya huit ans je faisais
du commercial je tapais au club bonjour
parce que je fais bon c'est bien ce que
tu fais mais voir l'erreur ailleurs on
n'a pas de souci j'ai attaqué notre
livre qui sortent à chaque fois qu'il ya
un livre qui sort en début d'année mais
on passe une étape a été le cas dans le
sport ça a été le cas dans le cinéma et
à chaque fois avec la civis qui a été
mis à un qui a été lancée on va en
parler je pense tout à l'heure mais ce
numéro d'appel est géré par le la
commission indépendante contre l'inceste
et les violences sexuelles
voilà on passe une étape à chaque fois
les lois changent aussi en faveur des
victimes même s'il ya des associations
qui sont pas contentes de ce qui passe
mais nous on est favorable par exemple
ce qui est un délai de prescription
parce que ce qu'on oublie c'est que ce
délai de prescription des serveurs
beaucoup de victimes pour porter plainte
alors il ya des victimes qui luttent
contre l'impasse crédibilité nous on est
favorable à ce nous à ce délai de
prescription parce que je peux vous
garantir qu'il ya beaucoup de victimes
qui vont porter plainte parce que savent
qu'après ça sera trop tard donc ça fait
ch il faut le voir comme ça et donc
aujourd'hui le sujet pendant est sur la
table et c'est beaucoup plus facile
effectivement on a un ou une ministre
ministre des sports qui a pris le
taureau par les cornes en 2018 dès
qu'elle a pris ses fonctions n'a pas
attendu qu'ils aient tous ces problèmes
dans le sport pour mettre en place des
choses sur le bizutage sur le contrôle
de leurs habilités aussi des bénévoles
est un prédateur qui sortait de
détention elle pouvait revenir
déhanchant sportif en tant que bénévole
et reproduire les actes pour lesquels il
avait été condamné sans filtre j'agis de
fédérations changer de celui orange et
al hilal et au foot us d'incroyables
fais juste mon rapide il a été condamné
à combien dans une prison disant ok bon
il a fait quatre ans et demi et pour
quelles raisons pour quelle raison il a
bien bien prison il avait déjà 520 jours
de remise de peine un jour par semaine
lors de conduite en les années qu'est-ce
qui s'entraîne en plein de pensées de 10
à 8 ans et au milieu de ses 8 ans
la remise de peine jours après 60 ans